that's in my will because people are
going to visit me
Khloe Kardashian reveals a shocking
clause in her will and what Coco wants
Coco gets
the good American founder makes the
confession on the famous family's Hulu
series The Kardashians during a chat
with her sister Kylie and Mom Chris who
just had hip replacement surgery Kim
asked the doctor to save her my bones so
she can make jewelry out of it like what
kind
creepy remember when you wanted your
ashes you want to be cremated and made
into necklaces that's a great idea
that's weird no it's not
I'm gonna go with cocoa on this one love
you Chris but it's a little out there
for me thank you I don't even know why
we need to get buried I just want to be
cremated but like why can't we no Kylie
doesn't want me to be cremated my family
and I we talk about wills death we tell
each other what our wishes would be if
something terrible were to happen if I'm
in a coma I'm still getting my nails
done once a week and that's in my will
because people are going to visit me
yep Chloe hasn't legally documented that
nothing should stand in the way of her
Manny's not even a coma I'm gonna figure
it all out I promise you but that's not
Chloe's only Beauty confession tune in
because you never know what's gonna
happen the reality star admits she's
thinking about going under the knife to
boost her bra size I'm really
contemplating getting my boobs done it's
just something I think oh let's do it
together
okay is that weird mother-daughter boob
jobs I don't know what's weird anymore
gotta love the support for Mama Chris
that's what we do I'm wearing a latex
top with like a bra top so they look
great right now and I wish they look
like this all the time I just want
Fuller like when you see me in a bikini
I don't have like cleavage like my
sisters have like this
uh ample cleavage that I'm like I don't
know you just gotta see them without
this top on that's for another show well
we'll just have to wait and see if Chloe
goes through with it but one thing's for
sure she's always keeping it real what
is in the media is sort of things that
we feel we need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives back in April Chloe
addressed all the online speculation
that she had gotten a nose job not only
did she confirm it she doubled down
tweeting that her only regret was that
she didn't do it sooner my whole life I
would say I've always wanted my nose
done like forever but it's in the middle
of your face and it's scary to think
about but I finally got the courage and
I did it and I love it
[Music]
thank you